For months, Israel has been divided by Prime Minister Binyamin Netanyahu’s...
...attempts to weaken the judiciary
But as the country faces war with Hamas, some of those differences have been set aside
Netanyahu has formed a unity government...
...and for the time being sidelined the far-right players in his coalition
But after the war, will that help him remain in office?
I think you should certainly never count Netanyahu out
That is something that we have all learned over the past decade and a half
But I do think it is hard to see how he emerges from this politically
We’ve seen some very striking scenes over the past few days...
...something that a lot of Israelis have been pointing out...
...is that the Israeli government has been almost invisible since Saturday
Ministers, you would expect them to be visiting hospitals...
...visiting the wounded, visiting people who can’t return to their homes...
...because their homes were destroyed
But there hasn’t been much of that happening...
...and we know why, because the handful of ministerial visits that have taken place...
...we’ve seen very angry videos of ordinary Israelis...
...shouting down members of this government
There is just tremendous public anger...
...not just Netanyahu himself, but also at the government
I’ve heard this in talking to Israelis...
...you’ve had people who are right-wing, people who are religious in Israel...
...who have noticed over the past few days...
...that the people being called up to serve in the army now
The people who rushed on Saturday to try and free besieged kibbutzim...
...in southern Israel and help survivors of the massacre
Some of them were left-wingers...
...and so this idea that Netanyahu has pushed for many, many years...
...that the Israeli left is unpatriotic and it undermines Israel’s security...
...I think people have realised that that might not be true over the past few days
Netanyahu will try and do what he always does...
...which is shift the blame to someone else
He will blame the generals and the spy chiefs for an intelligence failure
And certainly they deserve some of the blame
And I am sure there will be a commission of inquiry...
...that looks into what went wrong, but I don’t think it’s going to work this time
I don’t think Netanyahu is going to be able to shift...
...all the blame away from himself
Any positive change would start with new political leadership on both sides
I think there is a bit of optimism that this will move Israeli politics...
...in a more centrist direction...
...and that would be a good thing for an Israel...
...that has been torn apart by political tumult over the past year
And so I think in terms of domestic politics...
...it might help to moderate the trend of recent years...
...but when it comes to the Palestinians...
...I think it will nudge Israeli politics in the other direction